Donald Trump's heroic summit with North
Korea is quickly imploding before his
and our very eyes Trump during a meeting
with the South Korean president moon
jae-in yesterday starting to refer to
the summit in certainly more
linguistically uncertain terms like if
it happens and just generally using
totally different language than the sort
of inevitable and unstoppable victory
language that he was using just a couple
of weeks ago let's check out the video
let's watch the full minute and a half
or so to really try to gauge what Trump
knows what Trump is thinking at this
time and the sort of level of confidence
that he's portraying which is
significantly lower than what it was
just a couple weeks ago done where
things stand with with the summit
president moons national security
adviser on the way here seem to think
that things are on track in it this will
Idina well we're moving along and we'll
see what happens there are certain
conditions that we want and I think
we'll get those conditions and if we
don't we don't have the meeting and
frankly it has a chance to be a great
great meeting for North Korea and a
great meeting for the world if it
doesn't happen maybe it'll happen later
maybe it'll happen at a different time
but we will see but we are talking the
meeting scheduled as you know on June
12th in Singapore and whether or not it
happens you'll be knowing pretty soon
but we're talking right now you have an
idea about denuclearization would take
place would I do I have a very strong
idea how it takes place and it must take
place that's what we're talking about it
must take place so but I have a very
strong idea and I have very strong
opinions on the subject I also have very
strong opinions that North Korea has a
chance to be a great country and it
can't be a great country under the
circumstances that they're living right
now but North Korea has a chance really
to be a great country and I think they
should seize the opportunity and we'll
soon find out whether or not they want
to do that yes I don't want to say that
there's no reason to discuss that I can
say this that for a short period of time
we've been dealing with North Korea and
it's been a you know good experience we
have three hostages back they're home
they're living with their families
they're very very happy and so I can
only speak for a very short period of
time but it's been a relationship that
seems to be working and we'll see how
long it continues to work hopefully it's
gonna work for a long time just so all
of a sudden if it happens we hope it
happens we don't know supposedly On June
12th Trump now talking about conditions
not something he was talking about
before and this is not a surprise right
because from day one Trump understood
nothing about North Korea right first
Trump seemed to think it was notable
that Kim jong-un wanted to meet with him
as if it were an accomplishment when of
course North Korean leaders have been
wanting to meet with American presidents
for years simply for the PR and the
propaganda value of it it's the American
leaders who have chosen not to meet with
Kim jong-un then Trump clearly didn't
understand that when North Korea said
they'd stop nuclear research it was
after their main nuclear test site
effectively fell apart then Trump had no
idea that when North Korea says Korean
the denuclearization that's code for
American troops leaving South Korea he
seemed completely clueless about that
and then last week we finally heard from
North Korea that they're actually
canceling a meeting with South Korea
threatening to cancel the summit with
the United States if South Korea and the
u.s. don't stop these military training
exercises in the area and then yesterday
as we discussed on the program
extensively we learned that Donald
Trump's own staff is worried that Trump
doesn't really fully grasp the situation
in North Korea so all along it was clear
that Trump was missing this sort of key
basic knowledge about this and now it
seems to have gotten through to him that
the entire thing might be a play to just
make him look silly and this is the
clearest indication that there may be no
summit whatsoever and it is not at all
shocking and to be clear I'm not
cheering it right I've been advocating
North the humanitarian crisis in North
area has been one of the sort of
steadfast issues on this program for
more than a decade since I became aware
of the crisis I have been wanting
changed for the better for the North
Korean people I want Trump to succeed on
this to the extent that he's even a
player in the situation but there's
never been an indication that Trump is
actually set up to succeed it's now
becoming very clear publicly the one way
in which this is actually a good thing
is that it's clear Trump can't actually
handle the negotiations it would really
be bad if Trump had to sit down with Kim
jong-un it would be truly bad because
he's simply not capable of it and I
believe that over the long term if the
goal is improving circumstances for the
North Korean people and for everybody
else who might be affected by the
threats of North Korea keeping trump
away from Kim jong-un might actually
present the best chance for real
improvements for the North Korean people
adding to this chaos is a new report
that Kim jong-un is reportedly worried
that when he leaves North Korea to go to
Singapore for the summit next month if
indeed it happens on June 12th that
there could be a military coup that
takes power away from him and he ends up
out of power which of course would be
great I don't know if it's accurate
there's that that phrase I forget who
it's attributed to correctly or
incorrectly something like just because
you're paranoid doesn't mean they aren't
out to get you and I have no idea
whatsoever whether it's actually likely
that Kim jong-un would be ousted from
power by a military coup if he went to
Singapore for a few days but that
certainly is in line with his
long-standing paranoia and sort of the
general paranoia of North Korean leaders
one one after the other so zero percent
surprised that this very quickly seems
to be a summit that may never actually
happen and that that might actually be
for the better the video you just
finished watching was made possible by
you through the membership program you
can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership